first let us recap Joe Biden's very
troubling weekend that began with yet
another bizarre reference to lying dog
face Pony soldiers take a look
now as you some of you know I'd usually
come down and say hi to Oliver they'd
tell me there's a storm coming in
is that right it's still is this still
the deal
that's the truth now don't make a lie
as that that scene in John Wayne movie
don't make me a dog-faced lion pony
soldier
all right
it just is cringe-worthy every time
without exception anyway short time
later Biden seemed to completely
malfunction at the safer Community
summer this was in Connecticut which
itself is a complete joke since Biden
has done absolutely positively nothing
to make any American city or town safer
but he did end with a proclamation
dedicated to the late Queen of England
you know God saved the queen take a look
all right God Save the Queen man
[Applause]
foreign
S at the bottom of the paper now it says
Exit left exit right I don't know and no
one seems to know why Biden ended the
speech with God saved the queen man but
according to axios even his own age
they're mystified did he think uh he was
in England uh does he believe the queen
is still alive anybody's guess remember
this was a speech about supposedly about
gun control in West Hartford Connecticut
this event did not have a single thing
to do with the Queen of England the next
day even more unusual behavior from Joe
Biden on Saturday he traveled to
Philadelphia where Democratic senator
John Federman dressed up in his best
hoodie and athletic shorts to greet the
president on the tarmac the main focus
of this visit was the horrific I-95
bridge collapse in Philly and as a
reminder here's how fetterman described
the dire situation last Wednesday take a
look
I I
would would just
um
really like the you know the 95
95-95
you know
um you know obviously that you know
you're pretty much preoccupied with with
95.
95 95 95 don't worry the Democrats in
charge of your government have the
situation totally under control don't
worry I'm sure that Putin and president
XI and the Moses in Iran and Kim Jong-un
none of them are watching this disaster
anyway but you got fetterman Feinstein
Biden and Kamala Harris gee this country
is in great hands isn't it at pothole
Pete into the mix and I'm sure that 95
will be fixed in no time anyway here if
Senator fetterman introducing Biden in
Philadelphia take a look at this
I'm standing next to the president again
next to a collapsed Bridge here and he
is here to commit to work with the
governor and the the the delegation to
make sure that we get this fixed quick
fast as well too this is a president
that is committed to infraction yeah and
then on top of that the the jewel
kind of a
law of the infection inflation uh bill
that is going to make sure that there's
going to be Bridges all across like this
all across the America getting rebuilt
even Joe Biden was cringing fetterman is
clearly struggling from his serious
cognitive issues sadly so is the leader
of his party take a look
the president United States called me to
see what he could do to help us and that
says all you need to know about this
President and this man here so thank you
very much Mr President we really
appreciate it and we love you thank you
I might add if I didn't I'd be sleeping
alone
you have to explain I better explain
that some don't talk my wife's a Philly
girl
all right where are we going
so Mr President we put up a live feed
here over here that's pretty cool and
then we'll see a lot of things over here
that's from a few days ago
these are the people that are running
your country gave you a lot of
confidence need more evidence well last
but not least here's uh Biden proudly uh
well describing train tracks across the
Indian Ocean now it's only 8 000 miles I
wonder what the environmental impact
study would look like on this big
project take a look
well we're going to win and we're going
to help we have plans to build a
railroad from the Pacific all the way
across the Indian Ocean we have plans to
build in in Angola one of the largest
solar plants in the world I can go on
but I'm on I'm going off script I'm
going to get in trouble
gonna get in trouble and everything and
they're gonna get mad at me and they're
going to yell at me after that I can't
go off script they get so angry with me
now that would be quite the bridge maybe
Biden misspoke or maybe he's not
familiar with the Indian Ocean but let's
be clear he should definitely not be
running for a second term in fact uh I'm
not so sure he's able to finish the
current term based on what we're
watching every day now of course the
majority of Americans do not believe
Biden is mentally sharp enough to be
your president the evidence of his
mental decline is everywhere and by the
way in two recent polls Donald J Trump
in spite of all of the indictments and
all the non-stop legal uh attacks that
he's been taking seems to be clobbering
Joe Biden look at the Harvard Harris
poll that's Trump up by six so does the
new Rasmussen poll Trump is up by more
than two points in the Real Clear
Politics average but that includes a
Quinnipiac poll that I didn't feel was
real so tonight I have some advice for
my dear friends in the Democratic party
you might want to find a new candidate
or you can and take your chances and
anoint the big guy who has a lot of
legal troubles on the horizon that we
can tell you a terrible president an
awful track record lots of baggage who
can barely string two coherent sentences
together is there no one else in the
Democratic party more capable nobody hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else